[Música]
[Aplausos]
hace unos 200 años aproximadamente que
gran parte de las colonias que tenía
españa en américa se independizaron y
eso cambio tangencialmente el mapa de
américa cayeron los capitales del
virreinato y aparecieron de pronto un
sinfín de naciones grandes chicas pobres
ricas importantes menos importantes
etcétera pero cambio todo esto fue en un
efecto tipo dominó más o menos entre
1810 y 1820 una tras otra todos los
países fueron apareciendo insisto cambió
el mapa
españa tuvo colonias en américa durante
tres siglos el siglo 16 el 17 y el 18 y
de ese mundo sabemos muy poco y sabemos
muy poco especialmente del mundo
cultural de la colonia dentro de ese
mundo cultural de hay una parte que a mí
me interesa mucho que es la música y me
dedico a eso entonces hace muchos años
yo empecé a preguntarme si era posible
que hubiera habido música en las
colonias españolas en américa
y como nadie me sabía dar ningún dato
certero empecé a pensar un poco en
situaciones bastante obvias acaso las
madres no cantaban canciones de cuna a
los chicos cuando los querían dormir y
esas canciones donde estaban se habían
olvidado alguien las había escrito se
conservaban a lo mejor por tradición
oral cantaba la gente en la iglesia
había música en la iglesia en aquella
época y esa música como era profesional
había un conjunto rentado que cantaba y
tocaba o cantaba la gente canciones
devotas porque lo hacía para colaborar
había música en la milicia había bandas
militares en tal caso con qué
instrumento sí y con qué instrumentos no
y por ultimo cantaría la gente en sus
casas habría música en un casamiento o
en un cumpleaños para bailar para cantar
o para escuchar
la respuesta a todo esto es que sí pero
me costó un buen tiempo encontrarla
certificarla y tener una respuesta
verdaderamente certera
adolescente en el colegio
secundario descubrir la música antigua
se entiende por música antigua toda la
música que existió en occidente hasta la
muerte de bach que fue en mil 750 y me
interesó mucho el renacimiento y el
barroco una época que coincide
exactamente con las colonias españolas
en américa el siglo 16
repito 17 y 18 yo tocaba esa música me
sentía feliz la tocaba todo el tiempo y
me gustaba tocarla y repetirla repetirla
repetirla así con esa cosa adolescente
de hacer ya seria seria sería hacer pero
en un momento dije
como es posible que yo haga tanta música
europea y de pronto no haga música de mi
país es que no había música en argentina
en esa época pensemos que en los 80 no
había internet ni celular ni las
posibilidades que hay ahora de
comunicarnos de saber y de aprender y
que la única forma de intentar saber
algo nuevo era o preguntar o leer libros
busqué en las bibliotecas a las que
tenía acceso y encontré casi nada le
pregunté a mucha gente y tampoco
encontré demasiada cosa entonces dije
bueno iré buscando como sea y de algún
modo aprendí como si fuera un radar que
a la primera cosa que saltara que me
pareciera importante activada en viena
alarma una nota de una revista de lo que
fuera de divulgación de moda del diario
del domingo etcétera un artículo en el
diario un comentario de alguien una
palabra sabía que alguien era profesor
de historia y le preguntaba que alguien
daba clase de historia de la música y le
preguntaba pero nadie sabía decirme nada
el tema parecía no existir no importar y
en mi mente adolescente externo locura
yo decía cómo puede ser que si hay
manuales para aprender
a química matemática medicina idioma
geografía historia e inclusive historia
de la música no hay un manual o un libro
que enseñe la historia de la música en
américa latina' cómo es posible que eso
pasará a fines de los 80 cuando estaba
todavía en el colegio secundario ocurrió
algo que fue muy importante y muy casual
en el cine se estrenó la película la
misión esa película en la que actuaban
robert de niro y jeremy irons que
contaba un poco de la vida en las
misiones jesuíticas de américa del sur e
inclusive el ocaso de las misiones y me
enteré por un comentario de una señora
que la película era muy buena pero que
además tenía una música muy interesante
que era cantada por los indios guaraníes
eso me llamó la atención y dije tengo
que ver esa película fui al cine y vi
una película despampanante espectacular
una película increíble con las cataratas
del iguazú con la selva con un mundo
visual que yo no imaginaba pero además
con una música que era espectacular que
sonaba así y que a mí me dijo bueno esto
es lo que estoy buscando me parece
[Música]
salir del cine eufórico y muy contento
me compré la banda de sonido y la
escuchaba todo el tiempo y dije bueno
ahora tengo ya por fin la música de las
misiones jesuíticas que estaban parte de
ellas en territorio argentino y tengo
música colonial de mi país
pero alguien que sabía más en esas
preguntas que yo hacía todo el mundo me
dijo que no que esa música no era
colonial ni era histórica era música
nueva compuesta por ennio morricone un
compositor de música de cine muy famoso
y que era muy linda por supuesto pero
que eso no era una música histórica yo
no buscaba eso entonces bueno seguir
buscando preguntando y preguntando
a principios de los 90 en 1992 con la
conmemoración del quinto centenario de
la llegada de españa a américa hubo
muchos conjuntos de música antigua que
sacaron discos festejando de alguna
manera musical y aprovechando la
coyuntura esa del encuentro de dos
mundos
para esa misma época en unas vacaciones
fui a francia
como turista caminando por parís de
pronto encontré una disquería gigantesca
y si bien yo tenía muy poca plata en ese
viaje decidí entrar porque me llamó la
atención ver cómo sería una disquería
del primer mundo
años antes yo había tenido otro contacto
con la música colonial en las preguntas
que hacía me enteré de que había alguien
que tenía un cassette casete de audio
que encima era grabado no tenía portada
no tenía datos pero que tenían música de
las misiones jesuíticas con esa persona
me contacté
fui a su casa me dejó entrar pasar me
dijo que podía escuchar el cassette las
veces que quisiera tener su living y de
pronto puse play y escuché esto dice así
música
[Música]
esta si era música historia histórica en
la música de domenico zípoli un
compositor italiano que había vivido en
argentina en la ciudad de córdoba y que
había escrito música para las misiones
jesuíticas
estaba feliz la música existía no tenía
la partitura no tenía cómo llegar a ella
no conocía el conjunto que le
interpretaba pero yo sabía que eso
estaba en algún lugar y que alguien
tenía acceso a ese material entonces
vuelvo a mi viaje a francia entró a la
disquería quiero ver que hay por
curiosidad y me encuentro un display
grande más o menos así que anunciaba el
lanzamiento de un disco de domenico
zípoli con música de las misiones
jesuíticas de américa del sur
me dio una felicidad tan grande y tan
enorme que me acerqué y busque datos
para ver qué había y para más sorpresa
había una columna con auriculares donde
no podía poner play agarrar un par de
auriculares y escuchar esa música
entonces ahí descubrí que la música y lo
quería no solamente existía sino que
sonaba muy bien porque la calidad de la
versión que estaba en la disquería de
francia era muy superior a la del
cassette que yo había escuchado antes
ese disco que al final me lo termine
comprando porque lo vi y me gustó tenía
buen diseño y lo acaricie y no pude
resistirme fue el disco más caro de mi
vida y me costó 30 dólares en un viaje
en el cual yo tenía muy poca plata para
cada día desde los de mi estancia en
europa pero no me importó nada y sin
ánimo de romantizar ni de que esto
parezca una cosa casi como de dar pena
me privé de varias cosas durante los
días subsiguientes por tener el disco
pero lo tenía y me lo puede llevar a mi
casa a la vuelta del viaje leí el bucle
de ese disco y me enteré que el
repertorio había sido transcripto y
encontrado por gente de mi país me
contacté con ellos y lo que yo quería
era pedirles la partitura porque yo
hacía música y entendía que lo único que
se podía hacer con la música en ese
momento con la cabeza que yo tenía en
esa época era tocarla o cantarla o
dirigirla entonces fui y me acerqué a la
persona que había buscado el material le
pregunté me dio datos de pedir la
partitura y me dijo que no
y no me la podía dar porque había
ciertas restricciones con ese material y
no podía dárselo a nadie se me cerró ese
camino
y nada lo dejé como olvidado
años más tarde yo estaba en la
universidad en los 90 y con un grupo de
amigos hicimos un viaje de mochileros a
bolivia ya perú un viaje muy largo con
mucho tiempo con mucha energía con mucha
juventud y con muy poca plata fuimos a
ver que había ya descubrir cosas estando
en bolivia fuimos a la ciudad de la paz
yo seguía con mi obsesión de preguntar y
preguntar y preguntar a todo el mundo
qué pasaba con esa música se me ocurrió
bastante inocentemente pero con mucha
suerte que si yo iba al ministerio de
culturas de bolivia quizás alguien
pudiera darme una mano obviar me fiel
ministerio mesa de entradas una persona
que me atendió yo con mi cara de nada y
le dije hay alguien aquí en bolivia que
sepa algo de la música de las misiones
jesuíticas que había en bolivia
y para mi sorpresa me dijeron que sí y
que esa persona estaba en ese momento en
el ministerio entonces que me atendió
marco un interno habló y a los 15
minutos yo estaba con el musicólogo que
tenía el acceso a la partitura y no
solamente eso sino que la había editado
y la partitura estaba en venta en un
local que estaba a dos cuadras del
ministerio reales
imagínense la felicidad total este
hombre me dio muchos datos charlamos
mucho establecimos contacto me acompañó
a comprar el libro y de pronto yo tenía
la partitura en la mano y dije ya está
gane tengo el material vuelvo a mi casa
junto a gente un coro sopranos
contraltos violines etcétera y armó con
esto un concierto y me doy el gusto de
hacer la música que yo quiero pero ese
viaje que fue muy divertido y muy
intenso me permitió aparte encontrar
otras cosas y ahí descubrí que esta
música tenía un contexto que yo no
imaginaba altares inmensos policromados
altares con pan de oro que brillaban
muchísimo en la oscuridad de los templos
palacios con piedras talladas empecé a
preguntarme entonces bueno cómo era la
gente que venía acá cómo se vestía
cuánta tela había adentro esa tela hace
que el sonido de fuera mejor o peor que
comía esta gente
qué calor o frío hacía en cada lugar
entonces dije si no quiero interpretar
esta música necesito saber también el
contexto volví de ese viaje seguí mis
estudios y de pronto dije bueno la cosa
ya no es la música de mi país ni de los
países vecinos sino entender que las
colonias eran a lo largo de una
extensión casi continental y si quiero
entender esto tengo que empezar a viajar
para ver esos contextos que tanto me
interesan entonces se sucedieron una
serie de viajes que puede con mi dinero
y en el cual también los cuales también
aproveche mi tiempo libre mis vacaciones
fueron para descubrir ese contexto y
para pasarlo también también porque
también fui a la playa salí con amigos
fui a bailar fui a comer recorrí selvas
montañas lagos botes lo que fuera osea
anduve en todo tipo de cosas y en el
medio de eso yo buscaba material y fui
entonces por diversos lugares argentinas
con ciudades históricas fui a uruguay
fui a chile fui al brasil fui a paraguay
a bolivia a perú a ecuador a colombia
después fui a guatemala a méxico a cuba
y entonces estos viajes de una manera
bastante obsesiva y ordenada mientras
que me divertía salir con mis amigos y
hacia las cosas que hace todo el mundo
las vacaciones tomaba notas sacaba fotos
las fotos eran en papel había que
revelar las y eran caras entonces me
llevaba blogs y dibujaba tenía un montón
de apuntes dibujos lleve grabador de
periodista grababa la gente grabada como
hablaban como pronunciaba en el
castellano me imaginaba cómo se
pronunciaría entonces la música aquel
momento y se tomas de vídeo bueno un
sinfín de documentación que fui juntando
en mi casa terminé mis estudios
universitarios me recibí de músico yo
tocaba en conjuntos profesionales o
semiprofesionales y trabajaba para
costear mis estudios en medios de
comunicación donde yo escribía notas en
diarios en revistas o hacía programas de
radio en los cuales me echaba la música
colonial todo el tiempo porque me
gustaba pero esto trajo un resultado
impensado mucha gente se enteró de que
me interesaba la música y de que tenía
algún conocimiento al respecto y
entonces me invitaron a hacer un
conjunto
que interpretará música colonial de
manera profesional es decir tenía las
partituras tenía el contexto en mi
cabeza más o menos y tenía dinero para
pagarle a gente que tocara como yo creía
que se debía tocar y que cantara como yo
le entendía que se debía cantar no sé
qué dije bueno quiero ese tenor aquella
soprano ese violinista a que el
contrabajista etcétera y arme con eso un
conjunto profesional pago
de vuelta dije ya está tengo todos los
músicos el dinero para pagarles las
partituras el contexto ya está no me
hace falta nada más
sin embargo en ese momento descubrí que
lo que yo quería encontrar no era todo
eso aparte de todo eso me faltaba una
cosa muy importante que necesitaba
reconstruir el pensamiento y entender
cómo era la sociedad que albergaba todo
eso
y en eso estoy y en esa búsqueda me
sigue llevando mucho tiempo
y tengo la gran alegría de saber que no
va a llegar nunca a entender el tema
completamente porque tengo cada vez más
certezas pero al mismo tiempo tengo cada
vez más preguntas y acá aparece el tema
de lo que les quiero contar en esta
charla o lo que les quiero decir o dejar
a lo mejor todo vamos abriendo caminos a
lo largo de nuestra vida por cosas
diversas y en lugares diversos y por
saberes o por usos diversos sería ideal
que sus caminos fueran quedando lo más
ancho que se pueda que estuvieran
pavimentados
que estuvieran bien señalizados y que
estuvieran abiertos porque detrás de
nosotros siempre viene otra gente que
quiere entrar por esos caminos quizás se
quede a mitad de camino y desde ahí de
pronto se vaya para otro lado y llegue a
un lugar distinto o al mismo pero por
otra vía
quizás se cruce el camino nuestro con el
de otro entonces los que nos sigan
después tomen es del otro y vayan
también a algún otro lugar
quizás nos alcancen y vayan junto a
nosotros haciendo cosas y quizás los
superen y de ahí en adelante abran
caminos para que nosotros también los
podamos transitar y de pronto llegar a
lugares que no imaginamos o que sí
imaginábamos y no sabíamos cómo hacer
pero es importante que esto esté abierto
insisto que sea amplio que esté
pavimentado y que esté bien señalizado
porque eso permite que las pasiones los
intereses las profesiones y las
búsquedas se compartan y es la única
manera que tenemos de que esas cosas
crezcan y se desarrollen
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]